en el último vídeo logramos encontrar
cuánto vale la suma del vector a con el
vector b y llegamos justo a esto que
tenemos aquí ahora si lo queremos ver de
una manera mucho más visual
fíjate aquí abajo aquí tenemos el vector
a justo como empezamos y si nosotros
pegamos aquí el vector b y lo pongo yo
justo justo por aquí
entonces se vería más o menos así déjame
a borrar un poco todo esto porque no se
entiende nada así que voy a ocupar la
herramienta de borrar y entonces déjenme
quitar todo esto de aquí de una vez
ahorita no nos va a servir de mucho
solamente para que lo veas de una manera
visual déjame limpiar todo esto de aquí
ok limpiamos todo esto limpiamos todo
esto de aquí esto tampoco nos sirve esto
tampoco esto tampoco esto tampoco ok y
por acá tampoco nos y de esta parte de
aquí
ok solamente quedémonos con la idea
original y déjame terminar de poner aquí
a mis dos vectores tengo a este
originalmente este era mi vector ven y
este de aquí es mi vector am
le hace falta esta parte de aquí ok ya
tengo aquí a mi vector am aquí tengo a
mi vector b y bueno si nosotros queremos
ver de una manera visual cuánto vale a
más b entonces am sería el vector
resultante que parte desde aquí desde la
cola de amd hasta llegar a la cabeza de
bem y justo para en la cabeza de p este
es el vector que nosotros queremos este
es mi director que nos resulta de
tomarnos la suma del vector a con el
vector b si nosotros empezamos en la
cola de amd llegamos a la cabeza de amd
y después de aquí ponemos la cola de p y
llegamos a la cabeza de m entonces el
vector que nos resulta desde la cola de
amd hasta la cabeza de bem es el vector
que representa la suma ahora quiero que
te des cuenta que este vector que tengo
aquí también tiene dos componentes una
componente vertical la cual es justo
esta componente que estoy poniendo aquí
esta es mi componente vertical más o
menos esta es mi componente vertical
déjame dibujar una flecha para que
represente a esta componente vertical
justo lo que obtuvimos aquí en el vídeo
pasado y por otra parte tengo también
una componente horizontal la cual va a
ser esta que estoy poniendo justo aquí
esta va a ser mi componente horizontal y
déjame ponerlo con esta herramienta
también ok que por cierto también es lo
que obtuvimos en el vídeo pasado en esta
parte de aquí entonces este vector que
acabamos de obtener que es la suma de
estos dos vectores el vector a y el
vector ven también tiene dos componentes
una componente vertical y una componente
horizontal y bueno justo lo que vamos a
querer saber es cuánto vale
y déjame ponerle un cierto nombre a este
vector que queremos le voy a poner el
nombre de c cuánto vale a c es decir
cuál es la magnitud de este vector sé
que es la suma de estos otros dos
vectores cuál es la magnitud de este
vector sé cuál es la magnitud de este
vector c ok esto quiero saberlo y además
también
es la dirección o qué ángulos de forma
de aquí hasta acá para encontrar este
vector sé yo también quiero saber cuál
es este ángulo para saber su dirección y
bueno creo que lo primero y la más fácil
de encontrar es cuál es la magnitud de
este vector c así que déjame dibujarlo y
voy a ocupar este espacio de acá si por
aquí me dibujo a este vector c ese va a
haber más o menos así este va a ser mi
vector sé justo lo que yo quiero ok y
vamos a fijarnos un poco en sus dos
componentes este vector se tiene dos
componentes una componente horizontal
que es esta parte de aquí que se ve más
o menos así tengo a mi componente
horizontal por aquí déjenme ponerle una
pequeña flecha ok y también tengo una
componente vertical tengo a esta
componente de aquí ok la cual también
está escrita justo por acá y entonces
ahora si yo quiero encontrar cuál es la
magnitud de este vector sé cuál es la
magnitud de este vector c entonces date
cuenta que tenemos
rectángulo aquí tengo un ángulo de 90
grados y por lo tanto para encontrar la
magnitud de este vector sé lo que
tenemos que hacer es tomarnos un teorema
de pitágoras es decir la magnitud de
esta componente que es justo esto que
tengo aquí elevado al cuadrado más la
magnitud de esta otra componente que
tenemos aquí elevada al cuadrado es lo
mismo que esta parte de aquí elevado al
cuadrado o de otra manera la magnitud de
la longitud de c es exactamente lo mismo
que la raíz cuadrada de esto elevado al
cuadrado más esto elevado al cuadrado
pero creo que tomarme el cuadrado de
destruir el cuadrado de esto se ve un
poco engorroso así que déjame mejor
sacar la calculadora ver cuántos esto de
aquí cuántos esto de acá y después
calcular sus cuadrados déjame entre la
calculadora que la tengo justo por acá
ok train augusta calculadora y si yo
primero quiero calcular cuánto es tres
veces la raíz de tres entre dos vamos a
ponerlo así 3 le saco raíces lo
multiplicó por 3 ok y esto es igual a ok
y ahora es
entre 2 es lo mismo que 259 y si a esto
le restó a la raíz de 2 ok esto va a ser
igual a 1.183 así que déjenme escribirlo
aquí esta primera parte en 1.183 aquí
tengo 1.183 ok esto lo voy a elevar al
cuadrado y después a esto le voy a sumar
esta otra componente elevada al cuadrado
así que vamos a ver cuánto es este otro
componente elevada al cuadrado ahora lo
que me voy a tomar es la raíz de 2 la
raíz de 2 y a esto le voy a sumar 1.5
que es 2.914 así que lo voy a escribir
aquí y esto de aquí es aproximadamente a
2.914 ok entonces me voy a tomar la suma
de estos dos cuadrados y después lo voy
a sacar la raíz cuadrada para así poder
obtener ésta
magnitud que es justo lo que yo quiero
ok vamos trabajando con ello si yo
quiero esta cantidad elevada al cuadrado
ok vamos a elevar al cuadrado es 8.492
8.492 y lo voy a poner aquí 8.492 ok ya
esto le voy a querer sumar y le voy a
sumar 1.183 al cuadrado otra vez
saquemos la calculadora y ahora lo que
quiero hacer es sumarle a esto a 1.183
1.183 esto elevado al cuadrado ok y esto
es lo mismo que 9.892 ok y si a esto de
una vez sacamos la raíz cuadrada que es
justo lo que queremos la raíz cuadrada
de esto me va a dar 3.14 51
entonces déjenme quitar esto de una vez
no me sirve y quiero poner a mi
resultado mi resultado es lo mismo que
vamos a verlo de nuevo 3.14 51 ok
entonces esta magnitud va a ser
aproximadamente aproximadamente 3.14 51
de lujo 3.14 51 es lo que vale la
magnitud de este vector ser o la
longitud de este vector cm y darse
cuenta que esto tiene todo el sentido
lógico del mundo porque 3.14 51 es un
poquito más grande que esta distancia
que tenía nuestro vector al que era 3 y
bueno se nota de una manera gráfica
justo aquí que son casi iguales un
poquito más grande es la longitud que
acabamos de obtener de lujo parece ser
que vamos bastante bien ahora vamos a
pensar en qué es lo que pasa con este
ángulo
yo quiero obtener este ángulo para
también obtener esta dirección y es más
déjenme ponerle algún nombre este ángulo
le voy a poner el nombre de teta y bueno
si no supiéramos el valor de la
hipotenusa que acabamos de obtener pero
vamos a suponer que no sabemos él
de la hipotenusa como podemos obtener
este ángulo si nosotros conocemos este
lado de aquí y este lado de acá
bueno pues con la tangente recuerdas
cómo se define la tangente déjame bajar
un poco en la pantalla para que podamos
terminar en este problema
ok pensemos un poco en la tangente y lo
voy a poner con este color si yo quiero
pensar en la tangente en la tangente de
este ángulo que le voy a poner teta ok
bueno pues como la obtengo la tangente
es lo mismo que el cateto opuesto tohá y
el cateto opuesto vale justo esto que
tengo aquí así que déjame a atraparlo
con este con este de aquí y lo voy a
copiar y lo voy a pegar ok y entonces
esta parte de quienes sirven a esto lo
voy a dividir ok vamos a poner que a
esto lo vamos a dividir entre el bloque
vale el otro lado el lado adyacente el
adyacente y el adyacente vale justo esto
de aquí entonces me voy a tomar la
división
estos dos valores este también lo voy a
traer para acá y lo voy a poner justo
acá es decir que la tangente recuerda
que es exactamente lo mismo que la
división de el opuesto entre el
adyacente que es justo lo que ya tengo
aquí muy bien pero esto es la tangente
nosotros queremos el valor de teta
entonces theta podemos decir que es
exactamente lo mismo que la tangente
inversa la tangente inversa de bueno
pues esta división que tenemos aquí así
que déjame atraparlo otra vez todo esto
de aquí
y lo voy a copiar lo voy a pegar para
ponerlo aquí si yo obtengo la tangente
inversa de toda esta división que tengo
aquí entonces estoy obteniendo el valor
de teta que es justo lo que estoy
buscando y es más para no confundirnos
déjame poner unos paréntesis por aquí
para aunque esto lo hagamos primero y
bueno a veces la tangente inversa
también se le conoce como el arco
tangente así que vamos a traer por acá a
mi calculadora y vamos a resolver justo
lo que tenemos aquí
vamos 3 por acá en la calculadora ok y
ahora me voy a tomar primero las
divisiones de esta parte de verde que es
2.914 entre esta parte de aquí que es
1.183 así que vamos a hacer lo 2.9 14
esto lo voy a dividir entre 1.183 ok
esto es exactamente lo mismo que 2.46 32
y ahora lo que quiero es tomarme la
tangente inversa de esto así que para
esto voy a llamar a la segunda función y
voy a tomarme la tangente inversa de
esto que tengo aquí y de lugo me da este
valor theta vale 67 puntos 90 grados y
para redondear lo voy a poner 67.9
grados así que déjame bajar un poco la
pantalla
jones y para finalizar vamos a poner a
el valor que queríamos de este ángulo
teta
a aproximadamente vamos a poner el 67.9
67.9 grados y esto tiene toda la lógica
del mundo si te das cuenta es más grande
que 30 grados y de hecho parece casi el
doble más otro poquito de estos 30
grados que tenemos aquí y bueno perfecto
ya con esto tenemos la magnitud de la
suma que nosotros buscábamos ok y
también tenemos este ángulo que es el
ángulo la dirección de este vector que
nosotros estábamos buscando
y bueno date cuenta que una cosa curiosa
es que esto que tenemos aquí esta
magnitud o esta longitud de nuestro
vector que estábamos buscando este de
rosa es menor que la suma de las
longitudes de los otros dos vectores
si te fijas este vector tiene una
longitud de 3 y este vector tenía una
longitud de 23 más 12 5 y 3.14 51 es
menor que 5 y de hecho la única forma en
la que este vector resultante tenga la
misma magnitud
que la suma de estos dos vectores es
cuando estos dos vectores llevan la
misma dirección sin tierra en la misma
dirección entonces va uno después de
otro y en ese caso si tenemos que la
magnitud de este nuestro vector
resultante es exactamente igual que la
suma de las dos magnitudes en cualquier
otro caso es decir cuando los vectores
no tengan la misma dirección entonces el
vector que nos resulte este vector se va
a tener una magnitud siempre menor que
la suma de las otras dos magnitudes y
justo de eso te voy a hablar con mucha
más calma en el siguiente vídeo así que
no te lo pierdas